These young actors have come a long way in the three and a half weeks since they started rehearsing...
...Shakespeare's "Henry V".
None of them is here by choice.
Some people are here for worse reasons than others, but, I don't know,...
...I'm here because of assault and battery.
Tim is 15 years old.
Like most of the teens here, he was not a fan of the bard.
The judge sentenced me here, so my first thoughts were kinda...
...Shakespeare is not my thing, you know, plays kinda, I'd rather not...
...but it's a lot easier than picking up trash, you know, and doing that.
So you know, I gave it a try.
And he has discovered there's a lot to like about Shakespeare.
Assault and battery and you hand me a sword?
In Shakespeare, I didn't think that was going to happen, not at all.
I'm glad they trust us though.
The trust and respect shown by theater director Kevin Coleman is mutual.
These teens clearly enjoy working with him,...
Here we go! And reach to the ceiling. Left hand,...
...left hand. Breathing, breathing, breathing.
...as he inspires them to embrace Shakespeare.
Very nice!
Again!
If you present it to them...
...in a way that engages their imagination,...
...that engages their playfulness, that engages their willingness, which is no mean feat.
But if you can engage that, they come alive.